lors de la première guerre mondiale la
grande bretagne engagea dans le combat
une arme qui allait devenir capitale le
char on n'avait jamais rien vu de tel
sur un champ de bataille en 1918 il
participa au sein des armées
britanniques à l'écrasement des
allemands en france au printemps 1940
l'allemagne pris ses ennemis au dépourvu
en lançant une impitoyable déferlante
blindés sur le territoire français non
seulement cela mis le pays à genoux les
forçats également les britanniques à
fuir le continent en laissant les chars
sur les plages de dunkerque
cet épisode montre à quel point les
britanniques dur surmonter les
difficultés techniques tactiques et
financière pour imposer un char qui
pourrait affronter l'une des armées les
plus redoutable au monde
ce fut l'origine du chrono elle
le cromwell un poids lourd britannique
entre 1914 et 1918
richard autant que les avions étaient
devenus des armes de guerre déterminante
le char fut créé par les britanniques en
1915 et utiliser la première fois le 15
septembre 1916 ses débuts furent loin
d'être un succès il était handicapé par
une multitude de laifour
les britanniques inventaire le char et
en 1917 il savait très bien s'en servir
au début lors de son apparition en 1916
le char était très primitif et il n'y en
avait pas assez mécaniquement il était
peu fiable mais c'était un départ et
comme de nombreux autres systèmes
d'armes
il eût fallu du temps pour devenir
véritablement efficace en 1917 il était
devenu très bon en 1918 seuls les
britanniques disposer d'un char
opérationnel très supérieur à une
automitrailleuse même surarmés
les chars de la première guerre mondiale
n'avait pas de tourelles
comme vous pouvez le constater sur ces
chars il avait des meurtrières sur les
flancs de la caisse montée assez bas
pour pouvoir tirer à l'intérieur des
tranchées lorsqu'on passait au dessus
la caractéristique première de tous les
chars de la première guerre mondiale est
édictée par leur capacité à franchir les
tranchées et les gros obstacles pour
cela il avait besoin d'un dispositif
appelé hunting bing sur le toit une
grosse poutre de bois était déposé dans
la tranchée et permettait aux chars de
s'extraire de lui même on ne pouvait
donc installer une tourelle sur le toit
du char si on devait disposer d'un tel
système
les équipages travail et par des
températures de 40 degrés c'était
extrêmement chaud très déplaisant avec
une atmosphère chargée de vapeur de
fioul et de monoxyde de carbone
la fiabilité mécanique et est également
un problème majeur sur les premières
versions les chenilles cas c'est souvent
et il y avait régulièrement des
problèmes certains de ces problèmes ne
furent pas résolu avant la fin de la
guerre durant la seconde moitié de
l'année 1917 plusieurs officiers
britanniques considéré le char comme une
erreur coûteuse mais la bataille de
cambrai le 20 novembre 1917 leur prouver
le contraire
la première véritable opportunité
d'utiliser le chat au combat se présenta
lors de la bataille de cambrai en 1917
lorsqu'un grand nombre de ces engins
percèrent les lignes allemandes sans
bombardements d'artillerie préalable
prenant l'ennemi par surprise et
progressant sur un sol en bon état
plutôt que sur un sol ravagé ce qui
permis une percée spectaculaire
c'est pourtant là que les problèmes
inhérents aux chars apparurent ils
n'étaient pas assez rapides et l'attaqué
choix même si elle permis d'entrevoir le
potentiel des chartes
la prestation des chars à cambrai montre
à utiliser en grand nombre sur un sol
adapté et avec l'avantagé de la surprise
ils pouvaient être utilisés efficacement
la performance des britanniques ne
montera pas seulement ce qui pouvait
être accomplie mais elle fut suffisant
pour gagner la confiance de l'infanterie
et du haut commandement
les chars ne firent pas gagné la
première guerre mondiale aux alliés mais
ceux-ci améliorée disponible à la fin
2009 118 apporté une contribution
significative à la victoire qui obligea
les allemands a signé l'humiliante
armistice du 11 novembre 1918
je pense que la difficulté réside dans
l'image que le public se faisait des
chars bien plus importantes que ce qu'il
en était vraiment il était vu comme
larmes qui permettrait de gagner la
guerre il en était de même pour les
politiques
mais l'armée savais que ce n'était pas
le cas les chars étaient très utiles
employés en coordination avec
l'infanterie et l'artillerie
c'était un engin qui pouvaient franchir
les obstacles créer des brèches dans les
barbelés allemand et ouvrir un passage
pour l'infanterie mais ce n'était pas
larmes qui allait gagner la guerre
c'était une arme d'appui de l'infanterie
et les chars allaient-ils remplacer la
cavalerie
voulait-on des gros chars ou des petits
chars les gros chars lourds étaient
chères à produire si on ne pouvait
disposer que de quelques-uns d'entre eux
tandis que les chars légers montraient
des capacités limitées où il y avait un
énorme débat quel rôle le char était il
supposé jouer et est il censé combattre
d'autres chars devait-il combattre
l'infanterie était il une arme
stratégique ou une arme qui par sa
simple présence devait dissuader
l'adversaire et le poussait à se replier
ironiquement la majorité des leçons sur
ta prise par les allemands qui n'avait
pas inventé le char le seul qu'ils aient
jamais produit ayant été un échec
complet
la leçon qu'il retard était que même si
les blindés n'était pas la clé de la
victoire il pourrait le devenir dans le
futur si vous êtes allemand vous devez
gagner la guerre très rapidement si ce
n'est pas le cas vous ne la gagne et pas
du tout et ce en raison de la situation
géographique de l'allemagne les
militaires allemands virk une arme comme
le char leur permettrait de remporter la
victoire très rapidement ce qu'ils ne
voulaient surtout pas c'était se
retrouver dans une guerre d'usure qu'ils
auraient inévitablement perdu
jusqu'au début des années 30
les britanniques et est leader dans le
développement de chars et de leur
doctrine d'emploi pendant les années 30
malgré tout ce leadership leur échappa
les autres pays investissent et beaucoup
plus d'argent et de ressources
industrielles dans le développement des
blindés au final la grande bretagne
était loin d'être prêtes lorsque
l'allemagne lance à son blitz krieg en
france en 1940
l'opération fut dévastatrice le
blitzkrieg déferla sur la france les
français et les britanniques avaient à
eux deux plus de chars que les allemands
et la plupart du temps leurs chars
étaient meilleurs la différence résidait
dans le fait que les allemands savaient
comment s'en servir et pas les
britanniques le développement des forces
blindées britanniques et les problèmes
techniques a l'air de mal en pis au
début des années 30
l'une des raisons à cela la plus simple
fut la coupe budgétaire du gouvernement
en 1931 elle toucha particulièrement
durement l'armée la grande dépression eu
un impact assez différent en allemagne
car elle porte à hitler au pouvoir en
1933 et le gouvernement allemand donna
alors toute priorité à son armée les
allemands avaient mené le développement
secret d'un char en coordination avec
les russes étrangement tout cela était
secret en dehors des frontières de
l'allemagne et de la russie
mais après son arrivée au pouvoir
hitler aimait à afficher la montée en
puissance des armées allemandes et
surtout combien ces panzer allait être
efficace
les divisions blindées britannique
composée en majorité de chars légers et
de blindé d'infanterie furent annihiler
avant que la france ne tombe finalement
en 1940
bien que la plupart des soldats se soit
échappé tous les chars furent
abandonnées les années d'indécision et
d'économie qui avait freiné le
développement des chars britannique
revinrent hanter le ministère de la
guerre
face à la toute-puissance et à la
flexibilité des panzer division
allemande
les stratèges britanniques furent forcés
de repenser leur doctrine d'emploi des
chars d'entraînement et d'équipement
ce fut un réveil difficile un nombre
incalculable de rumeurs naquit de cette
mythique invincibilité des chars
allemands alors qu'ils étaient tout le
contraire
et bien souvent moins bon que les chars
français ou britanniques
il est intéressant de voir que les
russes aussi subir les effets de la
propagande allemande ce qui déclencha la
course à la puissance jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre les britanniques eux ne s'y
prêtaient jamais les allemands savaient
exactement ce que nous projetions il
vient fréquemment en angleterre nous
rendre des visites courtes formelle et
savamment organisés ils venaient
observait une division blindée son mode
de fonctionnement échanger des
informations avec les britanniques qui
la commande est ils tirèrent de ces
échanges de nombreux enseignements
qu'ils appliquent air à leur propre
conception de l'utilisation des blindés
haïti comme je les dis fut largement
développée sur le front russe
en réalité les allemands étaient en
retard sur les russes mais il était en
avance sur nous au moment où nous
allions devoir les affronter
au début des années 40 les chars
passèrent directement de la planche à
dessin aux chaînes de montage ou sans
aucune période de test les cruisers
tanks ce furent envoyés au front souvent
avec des résultats désastreux
au début de la guerre il ya plus de
pertes liées à des engins défectueux
qu'au feu de l'ennemi
les quelques années qui s'écoulèrent
entre la conception et la production de
masse signifiait que les chars
britannique arrivait sur le champ de
bataille bien après le moment où ils en
on avait besoin ce délai signifiait que
les modèles qui furent conçus au début
de la guerre était déjà en retard sur
leurs homologues allemands
je pense qu'il y avait une confusion au
sein de l'armée concernant ce qui était
nécessaire pour la guerre mécanisée du
futur et qu'au final les britanniques
conclure qu'ils avaient besoin d'une
grande variété d'engins donc ils
tentèrent de concevoir une gamme de
chars qui pourraient remplir le rôle
spécifique sur le champ de bataille
plutôt que d'en produire un qui
pourraient tous faire de manière
efficace les britanniques étaient
réellement en train de développer deux
types de chars distincts un char léger
qui étaient principalement destinés à la
reconnaissance et un chat moyens censée
mener différents types de combats je
pense que les britanniques étaient
logiques dans leur raisonnement
simplement au moment où il devint
apparent au tout début de la guerre que
cela ne fonctionnait pas il n'a juste et
repas leurs efforts et ne modifiaient ni
leur concept ni la façon dont ils
produisaient les chars je pense donc que
c'est dans cette incapacité à s'adapter
que réside le problème
le crossover serbie au sein des forces
britanniques en afrique du nord jusqu'à
l'arrivée du groupe américain mais à la
fin de la très longue chaîne de
développement des cruisers tanxxx au
cours de la guerre un char se distingua
qui non seulement gagné le respect et
l'affection des tankistes anglais mais
propulsa également la technologie
britanniques vers les sommets au niveau
mondial le cromwell
le premier cruiser tank l'a9 avec son
équipage de six hommes l'a9 entama sa
carrière comme chars moyens une
classification qui changea par la suite
pour devenir un cruiser temps la maaf et
est armé d'un canon de deux livres et de
trois mitrailleuses de 7,65 mm son
blindage faisait plus de 14 mm
d'épaisseur son bloc moteur à eux s'est
développée 150 chevaux propulsant
l'engin à une vitesse de 30 km avec 180
km d'autonomie
bien que les premiers tests et démontrer
le surpoids de ce char et une tendance à
des chenilles et vigueur ce travail là
dessus une année supplémentaire et en
les premiers exemplaires été livré en
france en egypte et en grèce mais les
problèmes d'approvisionnement qui avait
plombé le développement de l'a 9 était
loin d'être résolue certains exemplaires
avaient été livrées sans le canon de
deux livres tandis que ceux qui avaient
le canon n'avait pas de munitions il n'y
avait pas de pièces détachées ni
d'outils et trop peu de soldats étaient
formés à la réparation et à la
maintenance de ces engins les origines
de l'a9 sont très floues il fut conçu au
départ en réponse à une demande
concernant un char de soutien de
l'infanterie c'est pour cela qu'il
disposait de deux mitrailleuses sous
casemate assez peu maniable il un
équipage important il fait finalement
utilisé comme cruiser sens mais au
moment où nous avions défini ce que nous
voulions faire avec les chats nous
sommes rendu compte qu'il était trop
gros trop cher et un peu trop mobile
pour son rôle de chars d'infanterie l'a9
avait une suspension très fiable et il
était armé d'un canon de deux livres ans
il était raisonnablement adapté pour les
campagnes dans lesquelles il fut engagé
il avait quelques limitations en tant
que cruiser tank la suspension n'était
pas conçue pour les grandes vitesses
c'était un très bon système mais fait
pour les faibles vitesses
ils n'étaient pas suffisamment puissants
le blindage de la nef était vraiment
minces je pense qu'il y avait également
des problèmes d'engrenages et de
fiabilité mécanique il ne pouvait pas
tirer d'obus explosifs donc sur le champ
de bataille
s'il se trouvait face à autre chose
qu'un char des défenses anti char par
exemple il devenait totalement
impuissant encore une fois nous ne
savions pas réellement nous en servir
même s'il avait eu un aussi bon canon
que les charrs allemand même s'il avait
été aussi fiable
jusqu'à ce que nos britannique
apprenions comment utilisé nos chars
comment les armés de canons antichars
nous n'aurions pas été bien loin au même
moment alors que l'a9 était en
développement
le ministère de la guerre commence à
envisager la prochaine génération de
cruiser temps ainsi en 1936 le ministère
de la guerre envoya des officiers en
union soviétique afin d'étudier la
question
leurs découvertes révolutionnaires la
conception britannique des chars ce qui
les impressionna le plus
ce furent les incroyables performances
tout terrain des chars bt russe qui
incorporait un système de suspension
conçu par l'ingénieur américain j walter
christine le ministère de la guerre
américains avaient rejeté l'invention de
christie il fallut l'évolution du
conflit pour que celle ci soit reconnue
comme l'une des plus grandes innovations
en matière de chars en 1936 non
seulement les chars russes étaient
capables de dépasser les 60 kilomètres
heure mais il était infiniment plus
fiable au point que certains d'entre eux
sont toujours en service
après ce rapport le ministère de la
guerre charge à l'anneau fils
mécanisation compagnie la branche
blindée du groupe maurice de commencer à
étudier la construction d'un cruiser
tank rapide basé sur la suspension
christine
prédateur du désert le cruiser en
décembre 1938
les premiers exemplaires du à 15
quittait les chaînes de production la
15e remplacera progressivement les à 9
vieillissants pour devenir le principal
cruiser tank de la british army
la 15 également connu sous le nom de
crusat d'heure était manoeuvré par un
équipage de cinq hommes il était armé
d'un canon de deux livres et de deux
mitrailleuses b e s à 2 7 92 mm le
blindage du cruiser était de 40 mm
son moteur nafil liberty de 340 chevaux
le propulser à 50 km/heure sur route
avec une autonomie de 160 kilomètres
mais
c'est le cruiser à mon avis était
probablement le char le plus séduisant
jamais produit ils pouvaient se déplacer
à une vitesse assez phénoménal lé tireur
antichar et les équipes de mortier le
trouvais très difficiles à ajuster car
il se déplaçait très rapidement et il
n'arrivait pas à le garder dans leurs
instruments de visée il se déplaçait
trop vite ce qui compliquait leur tâche
en termes de capacité de pénétration le
tube de livres ou 40 mm et est plutôt
bon pour un canon de 1941 en 1942 la
situation commençait à changer et le
pouvoir de perforation du de livres
n'étaient plus adaptés de plus il ne
pouvait pas tirer d'obus explosifs
nécessaire dans certaines situations
le problème avec le cruiser dans le
désert occidental était qu'ils n'étaient
que partiellement fiable mécanique
membres et cela a pris du temps avant
que ce problème ne soit résolu
initialement nous avons perdu plus de
chara cause de panne mécanique que du
fait de l'ennemi l'autre problème
résidait dans le canon le dos livre
n'était tout simplement pas assez
puissant pour être d'une réelle
efficacité contre les chars allemands y
compris les panzers 3 et 4 sur lesquels
le bureau bondissait lorsque les
allemands me rends service les panthères
et les tigres ils déploient hier 25 tig
en afrique du nord vers la fin des
combats et bien les pauvres cruise adore
n'avait aucune chance
le cruiser fit ses débuts en 1941 alors
que la campagne d'afrique atteignait sa
phase critique en septembre 1940
les forces italiennes avaient reculer
jusqu'en égypte depuis décembre 1940
britannique indiens et australiens les
poursuivaient sans relâche
leurs canons de deux livres étaient
adaptés à cette tâche et on février 1941
la plupart des charrs italiens étaient
hors de combat
naville gilman était chef de char au
sein de la 7e division blindée plus
connu sous le nom de rats du désert nous
sommes arrivés en egypte à la fin août
l'italie était comme vous le savez en
guerre et la libye était une colonie
italienne
les britanniques envahir donc la libye
il avait battu l'armée italienne
mais lorsqu ils atteignirent bengazi
leur lignes logistiques et est très
étiré les chars que nous avions avec
nous et lé crouzade heures ces chars
avaient été livrées par train à marjah
début novembre nous commençâmes à
progresser vers l'ouest jusqu'à ce que
nous appelions les barbelés une
véritable barrière de barbelés qui
suivait la frontière entre l'egypte et
la libye
nous eûmes notre premier engagement le
19 novembre avec ce que nous pensions à
êtres une colonne de transport italienne
les rapports de services de
renseignements disait que c'étaient de
simples camion italien
en fait ses camions renfermait des
canons antichars
le régiment exécuta une grande charge
qui se solda par de très lourdes pertes
les équipages de chars alliés courait au
désastre comme à dunkerque
par malchance et par manque de
préparation la riposte allemande à la
débâcle italienne fut intraitable
ils envoyèrent un as des chars romel qui
repoussa promptement et avec brio les
alliés à la frontière égypto libyenne ce
fut un choc pour les alliés il y avait
un autre motif de réjouissance pour les
allemands non seulement leur char était
protégé par un blindage plus épais et
armé du canon long de 50 mm mais il
avait également découvert un nouvel
usage dévastateur de leurs canons
antiaériens connu sous le nom de 88
je suis sûr que nous avons été touchés
par un canon allemand de 88 mm celui qui
nous terrifier tous car c'était à
l'origine des canons antiaériens
lorsqu'il vous touchait il mettait tout
simplement le char en pièces ses canons
étaient énormes
avec une vitesse initiale colossal
les allemands étant très consciencieux
et efficace ils décidèrent de convertir
leurs canons antiaériens un canon
antichar
il les utilisait avec une terrible
efficacité
on espérait toujours s'en sortir et
c'était souvent le cas
moi même je m'en suis sorti trois fois
et je continuais nous avions un sergent
qui s'en était sorti 15 fois et qui
persistait les malchanceux étaient ceux
qui étaient blessés qui ne pouvait
s'extraire du char lorsque celui ci
prenait feu c'était le pire des
scénarios est bien évidemment vous aviez
toujours cette idée dans un coin de la
tête
le problème pour les alliés n'étaient
pas le rythme avec lequel leur propre
char entre est en activité ni la
puissance blindés les forces de l' axe
les allemands savaient tout simplement
comment utiliser leurs chars et ce avec
un effet dévastateur
la véritable supériorité allemande je
pense résidait dans l'emploi de leurs
blindés
les allemands étaient meilleurs parce
qu'ils concentraient leurs charges sur
le champ de bataille
les britanniques avaient une fâcheuse
tendance en 1941 et début 1942 à
disséminer leurs blindés sur toute la
zone de combat voire même surtout le
théâtre d'opérations ce n'était pas bon
car il devait alors faire face à des
blindés allemands bien plus concentré
nous pensions vraiment que nos chars
était le dernier recours on nous avait
vendu le concept d nafil cruiser les
crusaders
nous savions qu'ils étaient extrêmement
rapide
ils pouvaient atteindre les 60
kilomètres heure sur un désert plat nous
savions que le canon était petit car le
canon était secondaire un canon de deux
livres soit 40 mm nous disions en
permanence que dans le désert nos chars
étaient de petites choses fragiles armés
de canons jouer nous allions en guerre
avec une chose pathétique appelé deux
livres et la première fois que j'ouvre y
le feu sur un char allemand
l'obus parcouru 450 mètres et se planta
dans le sable il ne pouvait pas toucher
le chat et même s'il l'avait pu il ne
leur est pas endommagé nous observions
nos munitions de deux livres rebondir
sur les panzers 3 épandeur 4 à 450
mètres de distance
eux ils utilisaient un canon de 50 mm
extrêmement puissant sur le panzer 3 le
panzer 4 avait un canon de 75 mm qui
arrivait à percer le blindage du cruiser
même de face à l'été 1940 il devint
douloureusement évident que la grande
bretagne avait besoin d'un cruiser tank
avec un blindage plus épais et un canon
plus puissant que le cruiser dans
l'urgence un canon de six livres à fut
monté sur des cruisers modifié en
attendant à vérité
remplaçants cela impliquait de supprimer
un membre d'équipage dans la tourelle
sachant que manoeuvrer celle ci requiert
trois hommes alors en novembre 1940 le
bureau de développement des chars publia
son cahier des charges pour la nouvelle
génération de chars de liberty était
complètement obsolète au milieu de la
guerre
ce moteur daté de 1916 il avait vraiment
fait son temps de l'autre côté le
météore était simplement un moteur
rolls-royce merlin dont on avait retiré
le compresseur et que l'on avait équipé
d'une transmission différentes
c'était un moteur qui développe est
maintenant 600 chevaux avait fait ses
preuves et est incroyablement fiable ils
constituaient un formidable moteur de
chars il fut utilisé sur les chars
britannique jusqu'à la fin des années 60
l'un des problèmes avec les chaînes
britanniques durant cette période
et ironiquement c'est un problème qui
réapparu dans les années 70 et 80
résidait dans la sous- motorisation de
ces engins mais avec l'arrivée du
météore ce handicap disparu le moteur du
météore et est dérivé de celui du
spitfire qui était un moteur très fiable
il était beaucoup plus technique que ce
qui avait été produit avant mais
paradoxalement plus facile à entretenir
et certainement plus fiables donc nous
commencions à posséder un moteur qui
fonctionnait
le cavalier la dynastie cromwell
commence
le cruiser mk7 plus connu sous le nom de
cavaliers avaient un équipage de cinq
hommes il était armé d'un canon de six
livres avec deux mitrailleuses b e s à
son blindage pouvait atteindre 76 mm son
moteur nos fils liberty lui donnait une
autonomie de 265 km il développait 410
chevaux pour une vitesse maximale de 38
km heure le cavalier ne fut pas utilisé
au combat car les cromwell plus rapide
et plus fiable et est apparue en 1944
mais il entra en service comme chars
d'observation et fut utilisée dans ce
rôle par l'artillerie dans le nord ouest
de l'europe
le cavalier fut une tentative logique
d'améliorer le cruiser
il fallait un meilleur blindage et un
châssis capable d'accueillir un plus
gros canons
le problème était qu'ils utilisaient
encore le moteur liberty quand on
augmente le blindage d'un engin conçu
sur un châssis légèrement plus grand le
moteur un sérieux effort supplémentaire
à fournir
alami 1943 l'état major général
britannique avait changé son approche
sur l'armement des chars l'expérience
acquise en afrique du nord avait
démontré qu'après une percée les
véritables cibles étaient les canons
antichars et les positions d'infanterie
fortifiée plus encore que les obus
perforant habituelle celle un char
capable de tirer un obus explosifs digne
de ce nom dont on avait besoin non
seulement les nouvelles versions du
cromwell allait être doté du nouveau
canon de 75 mm mais les exemplaire
existant furent rappelés et leurs canons
de six livres remplacer
développé à partir de ce dernier et
incorporant certains de ses composants
le canon de 75 mm tiré des munitions
américaines ce qui signifie que les
équipages pouvaient compter sur un
approvisionnement sans faille
le centaure
le second chars lourds appelé à succéder
aux crusaders fut baptisé cromwell de ce
nom allait être changé pour devenir le
centaure la principale différence entre
le centaure les autres cromwell tenait
simplement dans le moteur liberty c'est
aussi simple que ça à l'origine il
devait être doté du météore mais
malheureusement la production
d'émetteurs ne put suivre celle des
chars conçus pour être totalement
interchangeables
il avait en plus l'avantagé par rapport
aux cavaliers d'avoir un bon système de
refroidissement
il servit au sein du groupe d'appui des
royal marines le jour du débarquement il
s'enfonçait en profondeur à l'intérieur
des terres utilisant les chars comme
appui d'artillerie
le centaure était manoeuvré par un
équipage de cinq hommes il était armé
d'un canon de six livres et d'une ou
deux mitrailleuses b e s à son blindage
était de 76 mm au maximum
et son moteur neuf il dit bertie
développer 395 chevaux et le propulser à
une vitesse de 43 km heure pour une
autonomie de 250 km la grande bretagne
avait-elle finalement produit un char
qui pouvait réellement affronter les
panzer division
oui mais pas en nombre suffisant pour
avoir une chance de menacer la puissance
des forces blindées allemandes
alors en mai 1943 la production du crom
- elle fut transférée à la glande motors
le cromwell poids lourd britannique
le cruiser tank à 27 m connu sous le nom
de cromwell embarquée est un équipage de
cinq hommes étaient armés d'un canon de
75 mm avec trois mitrailleuses b e s à 2
7 92 mm le tout protégé par un blindage
de 76 mm
son moteur rolls royce météores
développait une puissance
impressionnante de 600 chevaux avec une
vitesse de plus de 60 kilomètres heure
et une autonomie de près de 280 km de
cromwell était destiné à affronter les
chars allemands tels que le panzer 4 et
son canon cours de 75 mm ou le dernier
modèle du panzer trois armées du canon
long de 50 mm et il était bel et bien
capable de tous les affronter mais
malheureusement il arrive à plus de deux
ans trop tard il ne faisait plus le
poids face aux panthères et encore moins
aux tigres
mais il avait sa vitesse pour lui
lorsque nous débarquer à mon normandie
les régiments de reconnaissance qui
devaient se déplacer rapidement furent
équipés du cromwell les brigades de
chars on était également doté un autre
de ses avantages résidait dans sa
capacité à franchir les pentes dans la
profondeur du bocage normand et gravit
c'est beaucoup mieux les collines que le
sherman qui pourtant était un char bien
plus moderne
sur le papier le crom - elle semblait
répondre aux souhaits des équipages des
chiens britannique durement éprouvée par
les combats mais allaient-ils rencontré
un véritable succès sur le terrain
il existe des descriptions faites par
des équipages de cromwell lors de leurs
briefings juste avant la normandie alors
qu'ils revenaient d'afrique du nord avec
la 7e division blindée
ils furent équipés des nouveaux cromwell
ils avaient l'espoir de pouvoir enfin
disposer d'un bon engins lorsqu'ils
furent briefé par leurs commandants
d'unités sur les qualités des chars
allemands il semble que leur
enthousiasme et été refroidis nous
envoyons des plaintes au ministère de la
guerre et nos généraux firent
probablement de même un ou deux d'entre
eux donnent elles mêmes leur démission
mais nous n'obtenons pas un bon char
avant la fin de la guerre c'est à dire
un peu tard
alors que la rampe venait de s'abaisser
nous sommes sortis du chaland de
débarquement
il y avait des corps partout et je me
rappelle le pilote nous étions tous
reliés par l'intercom qui disait bon
dieu caporal ou est-ce que je vais je
répondis droit devant toi et fais de ton
mieux ce qui me préoccupait était la
présence possible de blessés qui ne
pourraient pas se dégager mais nous
n'avions pas le choix il fallait aller
là où nous devions nous positionner s'il
y avait quelque chose sur le passage et
bien tant pis vous pouvez imaginer quand
nous sortions du char et que nous
regardions nocioni ce fut ma première
initiation
le cromwell eu son baptême du feu au
cours de la bataille de normandie après
le débarquement du 6 juin
la 7e division blindée tenait le
calvados à l'ouest du bassin de la seine
le terrain n'aurait pas pu être plus
différent du désert la zone du sud et de
l'est de caen était une campagne sans
couverts alors que la région au sud et à
l'ouest de bayeux et est un labyrinthe
de petits champs pentu enfermés entre
des aides ans et entremêlées les
villages étant reliés par un réseau de
chemins de campagne avec un char qui
misaient sur sa vitesse et sa
manoeuvrabilité la normandie était un
test pour les équipages de chars a lié
ce terrain apparemment tu idyllique ne
pouvait pas être pire pour les cromwell
nourou l'âme tout droit puis nous avons
fait une pause pour la nuit avant de
reprendre notre marche au matin nous
avons rejoint la petite ville de villers
bocage notre escadron de tête devait
s'emparer d'une grande colline à l'autre
bout de la ville qui était franchement
imprenable je les constate et après il
n'y avait aucun couvert aucune forêt pas
de buissons c'est alors que les ennuis
commencèrent une division blindée
entière fit une halte
elle fut forcé de se replier remplacé
par une compagne en sous-effectif
commandé par un lieutenant même le plus
stupide des sous lieutenant n'aurait pas
envoyé une colonne de blindés sur une
route à voie unique sur une crête avec
des arbres de chaque côté c'était
chercher des problèmes
les chars sont inutiles en environnement
confiné
ils ne peuvent ni voir ni manoeuvrer ce
que le commandant de la compagnie oman
riz aurait dû faire c'était de faire
avancer son infanterie sous la crête
reconnaître chaque côté de la route et
seulement alors envoyé ses blindés s'il
avait fait cela il aurait découvert le
lieutenant whitman et ses tigres caché
là se frottant les mains en pensant que
pour eux c'était leur jour de chance ce
qui serait des lives
j'ai reculé dans une cour et j'ai
soudainement vu un de ces énormes foutu
tigre allemand passé lentement devant
moi j'avais laissé mon tireur sortir
j'ai mis mon opérateur radio à la place
du tireur et lui a ordonné de charger le
canon je déciderai de prendre le tigre
en chasse car la seule manière de
l'atteindre avec nos petits canons était
de le toucher par l'arrière j'ai alors
ordonné au pilote de suivre le char le
problème c'est que nous l'avons suivi
jusqu'en bas de la rue principale
hélas ce foutu gars était tombé sur l'un
de nos autres chars au bout de la rue il
fit donc demi tour et nous nous sommes
retrouvés face à face à 350 mètres l'un
de l'autre
autant dire qu'il allait m'assassiner
j'ai cependant tiré deux obus qui ne
firent que rebondir sur la vente son
char ils ripostent a ensuite d'un seul
au but mais celui-ci ne rebondit pas
et quand vous étiez toucher vous aviez
exactement 12 secondes pour sortir de la
tourelle quart temps que vous n'étiez
pas sorti le pilote sortait par l'avant
ce qui était dans la tourelle ne pouvait
pas sortir alors vous posiez votre pied
comme ceux ci sur le toit en vous jetant
à terre en espérant que tout le monde
aurait le temps d'évacuer l'engin mon
tireur avait été tué un autre de mes
hommes sortant par l'avant fut tué en
sautant dehors le pilote s'en étaient
tirés il était en sécurité et je fut
éjecté de la tourelle blessé au visage
je ne me rendais pas compte et je courus
à travers la rue pour ramasser la radio
et rendre compte de la situation au
reste du régiment une division blindée
entière fait une halte
elle est forcée de se replier remplacé
par une compagnie en sous-effectif
commandé par un lieutenant
c'est incroyable les deux généraux de la
brigade furent d'ailleurs sanctionné le
général de division bobia skins le fut
aussi et peu après lors de l'opération
blue coat le général de corps d'armée
buttner subi le même sort
bien que les chromos elle était aidée
par les obusiers de 95 mm en appui il
jouait sur leur vitesse pour se tirer
d'affaires
un canon de 17 livres fut montée dont on
espérait qu'il allait résoudre tous les
problèmes du cromwell ce n'était pas
évident de monter les canons de 17
livres sur les chars britannique
il était très gros très lourd et les
tourelles des chiens britannique
précédente n'était réellement pas conçu
pour l'accueillir
c'était difficile
en fait il s'est avéré impossible de
monter une tourelle adapté sur le chrome
web
les tentatives pour surarmés le cromwell
et y placer le 17 livres échouèrent
lamentablement et à la fin de 1943 il eu
un besoin certain cruiser tank rapide
avec une protection balistique descente
et un canon capable de détruire les
derniers modèles de chars allemands
la priorité absolue pour cette tâche
était de trouver quelques ânes on
pourrait être montée sur la tourelle du
cromwell facilement et rapidement
mais ce nouveau char devrait être
construit avec autant de composants du
cromwell que possible finalement vickers
amstrong proposera une version allégée
et plus compacte du canon de 17 livres
le dernier les cruisers le comet
la plupart des gens considèrent le
comedd comme une sorte d'erreur je ne
suis pas certain que ça a été le cas le
comet n'a jamais eu sa chance
il arriva juste à la fin de la guerre et
il ne prit pas vraiment part à l'action
il resta en service dans quelques unités
après la guerre et finit par servir de
cible pour les chars à l'exercice car il
avait un fort blindage
cela a pris du temps avant que le comet
n'entrant services principalement parce
que les efforts de production des
britanniques étaient concentrés sur le
débarquement avec la volonté première
d'aligner le plus grand nombre de chars
possible requip en toutes les unités
pour le printemps et le début de l'été
1944 amex sous bien des aspects tout ce
qui est arrivé au mauvais moment allait
être repoussé à plus tard pour assurer
le succès de l'opération inverse l'ordre
et c'est pourquoi le comet n'entrera pas
en service avant la fin 1944 début 1945
il se montra être un excellent charme et
il arrive à un petit peu trop tard pour
avoir un impact décisif sur la seconde
guerre mondiale bien que le comet n'eut
jamais été qu'un cromwell surarmés au
début 1944 il devint évident que la
moitié du char allait devoir être revu
cette découverte était un revers le
comet n'en sera pas en service avant
noël 1944 se commettent était un
cromwell revisité caisse plus grande
même suspension grandes tourelles
accueillant un canon de 77 mm ce qui
était une version revue du 17 livres ce
qui en fait le mettait à égalité avec le
panthères allemand est probablement un
peu au dessus du panzer 4 à canon longue
en janvier 1945 lors de la campagne vers
le rhin et au delà
le comedd tenait bien la distance et il
ne restait pas grand chose en face pour
lui barrer la route
il continue à rendre de bons services
jusqu'à la fin des années 50
en 1945 la grande bretagne avait
finalement produit un char qui l'a
propulsé au sommet du concept de
crossover
après plus d'une décennie de coupes
budgétaires et d'indécision qui avait
plombé le développement des chars depuis
les années 20 l'angleterre réussit
finalement à produire un cruiser tank
qui forçait le respect le cromwell était
un char adaptée à toutes les formes de
combat mais qui ne brillait dans aucune
il arriva vraiment trop tard dans le
cours de la guerre pour avoir un effet
significatif sur son issue sa principale
faiblesse était son canon mais dans
l'ensemble c'était un assez bon chars le
blindage aurait pu être un peu plus
effet bien qu'il fût dans la moyenne des
chars de cette génération le comet lui
est un très bon chat et si nous l'avions
vu un peu plus tôt certaines choses
auraient été différentes
bon nombre de chars britannique détruits
dans les dernières phases de la guerre
en 1944 45 ne le furent pas par les
chars allemands mais par les canons
antichars
quoi qu'il en soit ce n'était pas facile
de faire face à un tigre allemand
lorsque vous étiez assis dans un chromo
elle ou un chaman le tigre avait un
avantage écrasant en termes de blindage
et de puissance de feu s'ils étaient
apparus deux ans plus tôt alors il
aurait vraiment fait la différence
à ce moment de la guerre les allemands
avaient plusieurs longueurs d'avancé
ceci étant dit ce char était fiable
grimpait très bien les collines et est
rapide et c'est vraiment sa vitesse qui
le sauvait bien plus que sa protection
ou son canon